it's so dope is it it's so dope it is so
dope
that was january of 2020 i hung out with
the cast of f9 in miami during super
bowl week and of course they were really
hyped to drop the trailer right
well then the pandemic changed all of
that but now they are happy to announce
that after multiple delays
the race is on to a june 25th release
and it's safe to say
the cast is ready crank it all the way
up
get back f9 delivered that's the only
way to say it
all i can say is blessed humbled
and grateful that's how fans will feel
watching the brand new trailer out
tomorrow
and we've got an early look yes
this film had an estimated budget of 200
million charlize theron is back cardi b
makes a cameo
and john cena joins the fast family as
the villain
and dom toretto's secret brother it was
a long time dumb
the fight scenes with you and ben look
bananas
i mean did everybody go home with
bruises fighting dom toretto
in the fast and the furious is like
being in the main event of resume
you get thrust in there with a marquee
talent on a blockbuster franchise you're
on the main stage in the grandest stage
of them all
you have to deliver whoa many in
hollywood hope the ninth film in this
beloved franchise will deliver in saving
movie theaters too
after they close down during the
pandemic i never realized while i was
making the movie back in 2019
that we were making a movie that was
going to bring people
back to the theatrical experience that
unifying thing that happens
when we go to the movie theater and we
are entertained as an
audience man we messing with magnets now
we're hoping that you know that more and
more people you know feel safe enough
and are safe enough to make it out and
and reopen those theaters man
[Applause]
you all still managed to find the spirit
of paul
and weave it through the movies there's
not a day
that we've filmed it's not a moment
of thought and creation that his spirit
isn't with us in the fast and furious
world
he's still alive in our hearts yeah it's
good to be back
the good news the cast is already signed
on for more
bad news the franchise will end after
two more films
there's a moment in the trailer where
the end of dom toretto is teased
could you kill him
because i'm ready if you are the
question may not be
if given the opportunity will i kill him
it's
will dom face his past or will he
continue to run away
i'm not approaching fast nine as just
one film you know i i'm talking to vin
and everybody
as fast 9 as the beginning of our last
chapter bittersweet will be
the the final chapter bittersweet